ah this hurts Hunchback of Notre 'adam -
of all the films that shouldn't have a
sequel this is one of them and of all
the films that people were telling me to
beware of the most when doing B sequel
it was Hunchback of Notre Dom - the sad
thing about though is even though it is
terrible it's terrible for different
reasons than I thought it was going to
be terrible I mean don't get me wrong
the story is a circus comes into
town and an evildoer wants to steal this
super risky Bell that just happens to be
in no trade ah it looks like any
ordinary Bell but on the inside it's
gorgeous and beautiful and full of
treasures get it get it one of the
circus performers his name Madeline
played by jennifer Love Hewitt
she's working with the evil villain
played by Michael McKean to be
romantically interested with Quasimodo
to lure him away from the Bell so he can
steal it of course a real-life romance
blooms between them but why revealed it
stolen before she can confess what's
really going on and of course she has a
tragic backstory that doesn't really
make sense she was a thief and he's the
only one that could look after her yet
really she can move anywhere and nobody
would know about there's a million other
ways around this but if that seems too
heavy and traumatic for you it's okay
Haley Joel Osment placed the child of
Phoebus and Esmeralda and this
introduces us to one of the biggest
problems of the movie taking mostly
Academy Award nominated actors and just
having them say stupid it's so hard
seeing so many great actors just given a
generic script to work with and
that really is the biggest problem the
script is awful from the initial set up
you know everything that's going to
happen what every character is going to
do when they're going to do it it's just
ridiculous and why do we need an
appearances can be deceiving story when
the first one was already in appearances
can be deceiving story but let's get to
the toughest thing to talk about for me
and that's the animation this was done
by PMS the people behind a kira batman
the animated series and a maniac some of
the greatest animation i've ever
top five all-time in my book but I'm not
going to lie they just don't seem like
the right choice here now that they
can't emulate the Disney style I mean
they look like the characters fine it's
just that this looks more like a Disney
Afternoon movie and what I mean by that
is TMS doesn't traditionally use a lot
of CGI Disney does TMS doesn't usually
use colored lines Disney does TMS is big
strength is not in heartfelt emotion but
more aggressive emotion Akira is
aggressive batman is aggressive Disney
can be aggressive but it's no more for
the sentimental side for example when a
character needs to be still PMS has them
almost completely still every once a
while maybe a little movement with
Disney they're always somehow moving
they have like a million in-betweener so
when you're holding on a face it still
looks like there's a movement there
TMS doesn't function that way it's
supposed to be a little rougher so the
more top emotional feeds they do find
like when Quasimodo finally reveals
himself she steps back she's afraid she
runs off that they did great but scenes
where it's supposed to feel whimsical
and magical and lovey-dovey that just
not their strong point I keep expecting
to see Wakko Warner come out and bash
someone with a mallet so the animation
is still good it's just not good for
this which is a shame because they do
sometimes pick some very bad American
projects so is anything good well
Michael McKean as the villain is
actually not that bad I mean the villain
sucks he really sucks but the voice is
legitimately kind of creepy and I never
thought I would get that out Michael
McKean the music's nice don't not the
song they suck at these are some of the
dumbest lyrics and most forgettable
melodies I'm talking about the
instrumental score I mean sure it's not
the first Hans bag but again
direct-to-dvd you we get it it's going
to be down a bit but for a direct-to-dvd
musical score it's pretty good
and when he expected Carl Johnson the
guy who did gargoyle that's a great
talent outside of that is not much it's
so hard to see so many great actor so
many wonderful animators so many
phenomenal talents thrown into just the
laziest dumb ass script
I don't even know how to fix it what
would you do with Hunchback of Notre
dumb - it just seems like the first one
ended perfectly I don't know maybe
there's a better writer out there that
can make this work
but for me I'm wishing that gave this
movie the broadway-style ending
[Music]
you